Clouds of gases joined
Gravity will start to fill that boy hydrogen to fuse
Making helium which then exudes
G:o
Pushing outwards against the force of gravity
For years
And shining brightly up here in space
What will I become a
Red war is the common. Why will I be huge?
Fusing elements with magnitude
Blowing
Billions of years and my fires still burning for change
Until my fuel source is all
A star is born from the last
In the stars
Starglo in the star
Shine with the star
Oh
With the star
Thank you guys so much for watching if you're wondering where that beautiful voice came from
It's this gal que le Thank You Mitchell and thank you for making me into a cartoon
Finally my dreams came true. If you want to download the song the link is below and we'll leave links for kailia
You can check out as well to hear more of her beautiful voice. Otherwise, we'll see you next Thursday for another science video. Peace